How did you actually bump into this whole um thing?
Do you want the long winded version or the short winded version?
Split the difference. Okay. This is our friend Lou. Oh, Koski.
She's a radio producer.
I was there 2008 and where is their southern Ohio Pike County,
Ohio and Appalachian part of Ohio. When you say Appalachian,
I think mountains and stuff. Is that the wrong image? No, it's the right image.
It's country. And why were you out there?
I knew someone working on the campaign since 2008 so this is Barack Obama part
one. This is Barack Obama part one. And that's why I went.
Lou says it was the end of October one week before the election and in the final
days the Obama campaign was pressing deeper into parts of rural Ohio than almost
any other campaign before it.
So I went and I followed Barack Obama volunteers around just to see how is it
going to play,
like how's his race going to play in a a part of the country that's so white.
So she went down to down to town with the campaign,
eventually ended up in a tiny little hamlet called East Jackson.
Not even on the map population, 400 or so.
It's right in the foothills of the Appalachian Mountains and it's a place where,
who you are, what color you are. Well, that just gets real complicated.
I've got white Irish, German and in and all this,
but if anyone would walk up to me today and say, what race are you? I would say,
Negro. I'd stand in front of the president today and tell him, Hey,
I am a negro and I am a proud American.
I'm not black as in color, but I am a negro.
I mean that's just the way I feel. This is clerisy Clery, Shrek, Claris.
He was one of the first people I met in East Jackson. Their legal documents,
I suppose the lie, right? Tell me what you're doing and clerisy.
I'm getting a birth certificate out to show you.
I think her experience has taught her that enough people think she's white,
that she goes out of her way when you meet her. This is a lego document.
Come to let you know she's black. Okay. This is how it reads just in your purse.
Yes. I keep this in my purse and yes,
it says Harley Harris. That's her father.
And then a comes over and it says color or race and it says what Negro?
It says Mary Marguerite. Salmons. What's it say? Negro. Okay,
so you go as black. So introduce to me your two daughters. Okay,
well you got to go with go there. Don't yet. My oldest daughter. Okay.
I'm Carlotta. Carlotta Hickson. I'm from East Jackson in Pike County, Ohio.
Carlotta lives right next door to her mom. Yes, and like her mom,
if you met her, you'd probably just assume she was white.
The only thing you could tell is black on me is my hair of a, it's frizzy.
That's it.
But I've witnessed black all my life and I guess I was just raised that way.
She stuck by it. Carlotta will stand and fight to the end.
I don't think you should deny a part of you that is there now.
My youngest daughter, Alison Manning, that's a whole different story.
I'm way too white to be black. She denies the fact that she's a negro.
Look at my hair, look at my skin. I mean really creamy cream,
cream, cream, lots of cream, you know, um,
let's just go really white. Don't ask me why, but she decided that she's white.
No, not decided a few years ago that I was going to be white.
I had been white since I've been 12 old enough to say that I've been white,
you know, and that aggravates me, that Agora
for me, it really just, God,
it just makes me feel mad and to understand like why their thing is so intense
leave. Do you think you just need to unpack what this area is all about? Okay.
Like about five miles from where clerisy lives is a town called Waverly and
Waverley was settled,
but before the civil war by a group of white folks who came up from Virginia
with the express purpose that it should be an all white town even though it was
in the north. So to kind of achieve this.
One of the things that happened is that a sign was put up on the outskirts of
town, warning black people to stay out of Waverley after dark.
And to this day we really is still something like 96% white according to the
census. So that was Waverly. Meanwhile,
right next door you had this place called East Jackson.
We're clerisy now lives and you know, back in the day,
completely different situation was happening there.
You had Irish and German Timberman who were mixing with runaway slaves and
native Americans who were running from the trail of tears.
All these different cultures were,
were blending and intermarrying and having these kids and then grandkids who
were racially very, very mixed.
But to the folks back in Waverly, all those people in East Jackson,
they were just all black.
No matter what they looked like, didn't matter what they looked like,
they were the other. And for people in Waverley, the other was black.
And so if you lived in East Jackson, you are black. Huh?
So imagine you're clerisy my dad's mother was a full blood of white woman.
And my dad's dad was a German. She's a mixture of all of these things.
And if you look at our family tree, you could say she's only one 16th black.
But when you are raised from a child up and you're told you're black,
that's all you are, you're a n****r.
Well she says at a certain point that just becomes who you are.
And I'm not ashamed. One bit. I'm proud to be a negro.
Very proud.
So you had these kind of twin communities right next door to each other.
Largely separate. They both had their own schools.
Waverley's of course was bigger and multiple schools.
And in East Jackson we used to have a school in our area and it was called East
Jackson School, little one room, school house.
And then in the late sixties early seventies the school board voted to close
that school and all of a sudden all of kids had to go to wave.
Like were pretty much everyone was white.
When we went to Waverly schools on Martin Luther King's Day, the kids,
the white kids at that school would hang up signs and go home n*****s.
And this was in the 80s was as, so that's when they decided,
well Martin Luther King's Day, we won't have school in the 80s. Yeah,
I heard that story from clerisy,
our sister Lanita from the neighbors across the road.
And I, and even more surprising,
and Allie told me when she and her sister got to school in the late nineties,
things hadn't changed that much. I got made fun of all the time. It was really,
really bad. I would have kids, you know, come up to me in class and say,
you know, well she's, you know, she's dirty, you know,
cause she's from East Jackson and they're all dirty out there. And you know,
when they would do the little check in your head at school thing,
they'd be like, Oh, you know,
she gonna have it cause she's black because I was black,
I'm going to have headlights. I, I, you know,
I'd come home and cry mom and be like, oh don't even worry about what they say.
They're, you know, you gotta be better than them, blah blah blah.
But she says she couldn't ignore it, so she started to fight back.
I would punch him, you know, just punch him.
Mom was constantly in the office because I was fighting.
But at some point during the eighth grade,
the principal with Ellie says something shifted. We were sitting in class,
two white girls were sitting behind her and I didn't even know these girls and I
was just thinking their mind in my own business.
And they came up from behind me and just threw this deodorant at me literally.
And they said, here, we thought you might need this.
Don't black people need deodorant. And keep in mind,
this is in the middle of class. Everybody is in there.
And the teachers there doesn't say anything, just tells them to calm it down.
And I was just like, you know, I tried to ignore him,
but they just kept poking me. Hey, hey.
They just kept, you know, poking me and telling me I was dirty.
Black people are dirty, you're dirty, you know, we know where you come from.
You're dirty, everyone's dirty out there, you're all dirty.
And she said at that moment, she just kind of gave up.
I didn't like having to fight.
I didn't like feeling like everybody was out to get me.
I wanted to be part of the group.
[inaudible]
not the outsider. It sucked being the outsider. I got sick of it.
Shortly after that class she decided I don't want to be black and I'll have to,
when I went into high school, I had a break, you know,
the summer break and over the summer I decided that I was going to transform
myself, my life. It was going to be a new start for me. That summer,
Allie dropped a bunch of weight, grew her hair long.
I started wearing makeup when school started up again.
That fall I didn't even look like I did when I was in grade school,
you know, or middle school. Um, did you do
well I started hanging out with the older crowd
[inaudible]
the, you know, juniors and seniors. So they didn't even know who I was.
People would ask what color I was. I was white. What color are your parents?
They're white, you know, and if anyone asks, well, can we meet your parents?
Well, she's gone on business. Oh my dad. Uh, he works a lot, you know,
great.
I have two hardworking white parents and you're never going to meet them.
She came home at night and she said, I had a wonderful day at school.
And I said, you did. That's nice to hear somebody that's black. Tell me that.
And she said, I told you I wasn't going as black.
I didn't talk to my sister very much either,
just because every time I would talk to her, I'd have to explain who she was.
Carlotta would be telling her friends and pointing at ally saying,
that's my sister and ally be telling her friends, that's not my sister.
This girl's crazy, you know, don't believe nothing she's saying.
Whenever Alley's new friends did run into her sister, they picked on her,
they tormented her teased and it throws the exact you,
same way they once picked on Allie or you know, calling her the n word.
Nobody likes you. Black people are dirty, you're dirty.
But did I dare say anything about it? No Way.
Actually Ali would lead a lot of the in. Yes. She would help him out. Right.
Mocker to make it fun of me can make her popular. Then she would do it.
But she would make you cry at school. Well, sure she was.
I saw her cry so many times
and I stood and did nothing and she wonders why we're not close now.
And you know, you don't forget things like that.
You don't forget who made your life miserable. She hated high school.
She would never go back if you paid her
and then you have me.
Mm.
I loved it.
[inaudible]
I had all these friends and I really felt like everybody loved me. Granted,
I don't know how good of friends they were because you know,
in a different situation they probably wouldn't have, but I didn't care.
I didn't care how they liked me. I just carried it
that they liked me. And still this day Ellie is that rotten little child,
its height and I love her to death. I do, but still inside.
She's still that little insecure child that wants be friends with the popular
crowd. After high school, Allie moved across town.
She lives in Piketon. It's on the other side away. Yeah.
It's another side of Waverly into a predominantly white neighborhood.
Carlotta stayed in east Jackson and she stayed black. To be honest,
the way I feel about that,
it really doesn't bother me one way or the other bothers my mom more than at
ball versus me. Oh yes.
Allie says it comes up whenever she brings a friend over to her mom's house.
As soon as they walk in the door, the very first question out of her mouth,
is it Allie tell you she was black? If she brings a guy or friend,
I tell him we're Negros. I want him to know what we are. I do.
I'll call her to the site or whatever, and I'm like,
do you have to do this every time? Well, what year? Shamed of us.
Now I am not ashamed of anybody, but I am not black. You know,
I am white. Stop doing that. As much as Allie and clerisy argue,
they're actually pretty close. Mommy's on the phone. Kids come here.
Nancy clerisy takes care of alleys, kids, a lot. Camaro. Mommy's on the phone.
They speak on the phone every day. David wants to talk. Come here, Kayla,
come here baby. This is the Nesa here, take this. Talk to mommy,
and that's Kayla. These are alleys, two children
now alleys two children.
They'll cry if you tell them that they're in their growth.
Caleb believes that he's white. He's got blonde hair, blonde hair,
and you know he's really Pale like me. And when you say, excuse me,
you know you're black, he will cry and say, no, I'm not. Either I'm white.
And she's like, you just ruined those kids.
Why don't you want them to be proud of where they came from? I said,
I told him he has black in his family, but he is not lying.
[inaudible]
when I got married,
my husband knew beforehand what he was getting into.
He lived in Waverly and he knew she lived in East Jackson,
that I came from a black community.
He'd met my family and said that that was fine with him.
And the further we got into her marriage,
the more I could see him becoming more and more racist.
So they split up, but he still had the right to see his kids.
And during one of the visits I overheard a conversation that he was having with
Caleb and daddy joined a new group and he wanted kill up to join it.
He said, you can't right now,
but when you get bigger daddy's going to introduce you to him. And he said,
we'd get aware white hats and sheets and we get to beat people up.
[inaudible]
and I walk in the room and I'm like, what are you talking about? And he goes,
oh, I didn't tell you about that.
No.
And there was nothing I could do about it. You know,
he had visitations on the weekend. Caleb would come back and he would say,
the God awfullest things. He would tell my mom, you're a n****r,
you're a n****r, grandma.
We were just sitting there one day and I don't remember exactly,
it was a black show on TV that we were watching.
I'm thinking it was a Tyler Perry movie, but anyway,
Caleb came up to me and he said, grumble, you're a n****r. I said, no honey,
I'm not a n****r. I'm a Negro. And he said, no,
you're a n****r. I said, who told you to say that, Caleb? He said, well,
my dad said he's going to get the KKK and come up here and what he's going to
do. And I said, my son saying that in a community where people are all block,
that doesn't give him much of a fighting chance.
Finally
he stopped saying it that God, he was young enough to where it could be stopped.
But Caleb is definitely a mini me of Allie, Allie, sister,
Carlotta, you know what I mean? Honestly he,
he acts just like her and Lenexa and even though she's only two years old,
she'll go around telling y'all, tell him on black on black.
So I think that will be another Allie Carlotta situation.
As they're growing up, they kind of want more for my family.
I'm not going to say mine, let them be treated the way my sister was treated.
They don't deserve that.
Hmm.
So as long as I can pass for White, I go by white
[inaudible]
sometimes I thought about leaving away, but I love my mom so much and
I could never leave her. But in the event that something ever happens to my mom,
me and my kids will pack up and we will leave the state and we will come back
and I will no longer be associated with this area with East Jackson.
It'll all be just a blur. I mean I want out now,
but I can't leave her
[inaudible]
she knows that. I told her when you're gone, I'm gone.
but he's her Lou oh cal scheme.
That story was sponsored by Ohio's hill country heritage area and made possible
with funding from the Ohio humanities council.
Also want to give a huge thanks to the radio show,
state of the reunion hosted by the brilliant outlets and state of the reunion
initially broadcast version of the story, which just won a big award.
They're an amazing show. We should definitely check them out.
State of the reunion.com I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.